this is my daily driver it's a 1994 Ford
f-150
it's a beaut I'm Sean and I'm Melinda
hey Sean thanks for calling the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave how are you doing
thanks for taking my call how old are
you
I'm 51 okay and what's your net worth
sir about 1.5 million okay we didn't
really kind of set out to build a lot of
wealth we we wanted to be I wanted us to
be comfortable to me comfortable was we
can drive decent cars and live in a nice
house and you know just go enjoy life
you know we didn't have to be
extravagant cruises and European
vacations and all that kind of thing
just to have a good life and to be able
to do the things we wanted to do when we
wanted to do how'd you get immediately
half dollars of 51 this slow and steady
investing strategy we made sure we made
savings a priority every month I grew up
in a middle-class family my father was
in the military my father was also a
veteran and he and my mother both were
very very conscientious very hard
workers however we didn't know about how
to live without living on credit yeah
all of my brothers and I we all worked
at an early age and so we kind of
learned the value of you know you you
work here and money so my parents kind
of instilled that work ethic in us at an
early age and when I joined the military
you know that kind of work that they
carried through later in my military
career we started to look at now we need
to transition back to civilian life one
of the things I did was I started to
talk to people that had already done
that and so one of the people I talked
to just happened to be a financial peace
coordinator going through financial
peace show this this is how you develop
a budget this is what you do to follow
it when every dollar the budgeting tool
when that came out that really helped
that was very really really helped
because we got away from the paper
spreadsheets and that that tool has just
been a really a great thing
in terms of getting our budget set and
then following it every month so what
was your income average through your
working lifetime I'd estimate about
$70,000 what was the high through that
period the highest about 220 how many
new cars have you bought I bought one in
1994 and I turn around and sold it too
much there because I hated half of the
car payment probably about 10 years ago
was when I kind of noticed that hey all
of this this foundation that we laid
early on in our marriage in our career
living on less and make savings a
priority and sacrificing sometimes that
built over time it's that you know that
the power of compounding interest and as
we progress down this this path The
Millionaire Next Door was the first real
book that I kind of that I read and said
okay this makes sense and and this is
how people do this and these are real
people that have been studied and
researched and and this is how they did
it I'm not a financial genius we didn't
do anything extravagant investing wise
you know we just you know followed kind
of basic investing principles and it
really became a matter of just making
savings a priority we didn't have a lot
of money you know early on there wasn't
a lot one thing that I found was putting
a plan in place sometimes working more
than one job job we chose to live in
places that we could afford that were
comfortable that were safe we drove cars
that were not new and still don't but
they're comfortable and it's good
transportation it's safe and it gets us
where we need to go and so after 20 25
years of doing that you look and you go
wow you know that's really quite of a
nest egg that we built so we shifted now
from less about the building the wealth
and more to what are we going to do to
make sure that we're not a burden on our
kids so that was really the big driving
factor for us was to not be a burden on
our children
to be responsible take care of ourselves
so this past year for Christmas we
bought them the Total Money Makeover
he's one of them got a total money made
into it and we sat them down and talked
to them about where we are financially
that kind of put us in into action to
kind of develop a plan to an estate plan
I guess if you will you can build wealth
whether your goal is to be a millionaire
or multi-millionaire or just to have a
comfortable lifestyle it doesn't take a
college education and it doesn't take
someone that has wealthy parents and
here's a lot of money it's really about
putting in the work and making the
effort in having a plan and working
together to make that become a reality